now of course there are still major
threats to the American people within
our own borders one illegal immigrant
just arrested in New York because he
wanted he's wanted on terror charges in
Africa get this another illegal
immigrant just removed from government
funded housing in the state of
Massachusetts because he's a convicted
murderer from Venezuela here with
reaction to all of this is 2024 GOP
Presidential candidate senator from the
great state of South Carolina Tim Scott
is back with us sir
okay so we're learning a lot this week
we're learning that a lot of people from
the Middle East including hundreds and
hundreds from Iran and Syria and
elsewhere they're coming in through our
Southern border tens of thousands from
China and Russia um what are can what
possible explanation can there be why
are they showing up now at our
border well it's it's a simple concept
the president has sent a signal to the
entire world Sean that our border is
insecure unsafe wide open and
undermanned this President refuses to do
his job the most important job of the
commander and chief is keeping the
Homeland safe you can't do that without
finishing the wall but Sean instead of
finishing the wall they literally have
been selling off the construction
material for the wall instead of using
available military grade technology that
sees underneath the ground and above a
wall they simply won't use it why is the
question it's simple they are looking
for a whole new brand of Voters States
like California allowing illegal
immigrants to participate in their local
elections is in my opinion the reason
why you see this Administration so
committed to an insecure unsafe wide
openen border because it adds to their
polls and the only reason why
you hear liberals and people on the left
they're going to say oh they call it the
great replacement Theory oh that they're
bringing in people from other countries
uh off of minorities and they want to
replace them um I really don't care
where anybody comes from as long as we
bet them as long as we do a health check
if we're in the middle of a pandemic as
long as they won't be a financial burden
on the American people it's not about
that if we do those things I don't care
where you come from do it legally
welcome to to family glad to have you uh
but I think it's it's a little different
in this way because aren't they going to
offer all of them eventually amnesty and
aren't they hoping by offering something
of such great value and worth that they
will be rewarded oh you're the party
that let me stay oh you're the party
that let me in and they'd be inclined to
support those people so I see it
differently than what they would accuse
people
of I think you're 100% right remember
this is one of the founding philosophies
I have about the radical love they are
interested in one thing power they will
manipulate people to control them they
are not interested in racial progress
they're not talking about how we can all
get along here's what they want they
want a monopoly in America that allows
for socialism to be the finance system
of our nation that allows for their
conversation around equity Give It Away
not earn it they're talking about
finding ways to eliminate personal
responsibility this Democrat Party led
by Joe Biden and the radical left are
more interested in power so they
weaponize race they weaponize
immigration they weaponize the countries
where they come from to suggest that we
are somehow racially offensive or racist
or Prejudice how about this we love
America as it is not how they wish it
was we have to stay committed to let ask
the front door and not a back door yes
okay you are a US senator you are a
lawmaker we are a nation of laws we are
a constitutional republic my question is
how is it that this president for three
years is not only enforcing the laws but
he's aiding and ab bedding and the law
breaking how come he has not been
stopped how come that is allowed you
know people ask me that question all the
time I don't have a good answer yes I
don't have a good one either thank God
we finally have a speaker in the house
and there may be more action coming
against the current president of United
States but the bottom line is simply
this it wasn't the 70,000 Americans who
lost their lives to fentol that started
a border conversation it wasn't the 6
million plus illegal immigrants Sean
that came across our border that started
the conversation it wasn't even the 200
plus people on our national security
watch list in the midst of Hamas trying
to create a Jewish gen genocide that
caused him to focus on our Southern
border it was
2024 and the election that caused him to
even turn the conversation towards our
Southern border this is just ridiculous
no other word for just ridiculous
Senator we need Republican in the White
House a Republican in the White House in
November uh to win in November and to be
there in January 2025 Senator great to
have you thank you for being was hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else